recently Hillary could not stop herself
from chiming in on Trump's impeachment
saying quote America deserves free and
fair elections yeah that's the one we
had last time that you lost meanwhile it
seems like every day there is more bad
news for sleepy creepy crazy Uncle Joe
303 303 tear on his legs in the summer
it is being reported hunter Biden's
controlled substance charge in 1988 was
kept under wraps while his father was
advocating for harsher drug laws from
the US Senate
it was reaction of that the author of
The New York Times bestseller witch-hunt
Fox News legal analyst Greg Jarrett also
the author of the resistance at all
costs Fox News contributor Kimberly
Strasse Gregg Jarrett we start with you
tonight Greg oh oh that's a problem for
Hunter Biden Joe Biden yeah both Joe
Biden and Hillary Clinton have more
baggage than an airport terminal Hillary
Clinton's docu-series is promoting
herself which is what her books are
about she doesn't promote books she
promotes herself and the reason is
because you know she has this persistent
MLK like dream I have a dream I walk out
on this stage of the Democratic
convention next summer and by
acclamation I will be the nominee
because they're deadlocked the the
problem is she's just haunted by too
many scandals the uranium one
pay-to-play scandal the email scandal
and of course the most recent she paid
for the Russia hoax and so you know good
luck with your MLK like dream Hillary
you had a great catch this week Kimberly
Strasse land it had to do with with GPS
is Glenn Simpson because what they're
officially telling us his operation
crossfire hurricane counter-intel which
Andy McCarthy says you can't have unless
the president signs off on it that would
be Obama but your catch was that fusion
GPS actually was talking about Russia
and collusion in May and meanwhile they
say didn't start to the what July 30 at
the 31st yeah exactly
this is very fishy Sean if you go all
the
relevant players here the FBI says we
weren't thinking about Trump Russia
collusion until the end of July you go
back and you look at Glenn Simpsons
Senate testimony and he says that he
only hired you know Christopher Steele
in May because he wanted him to look
into Trump's business dealings then you
go and you read the IG report and here's
what Steele told the IG he said Simpson
approached him in May specifically to
look into any ties between the Trump
campaign and Russia and whether or not
Russia was trying to get a specific
election outcome no where did Glenn
Simpson get this narrative this early in
the game well I think that's such a
great question I mean great what do you
take got it from American intelligence
agencies and likely the instigator of
the hoax which is John Brennan and the
amazing part is if you look at the
timeline and I put this in my book
within two weeks a Christopher Steele
comes up with the dossier at least the
first and second memos if you read those
memos that is an impossibility unless
he's he's just fed a bunch of garbage
and of course that's what we learned
from the IG report that it all largely
came from a sub source who was finally
confronted by the FBI and who said are
you kidding me this these are all missed
operations I got kicked give the last
word Kimberly I got a kick out of the
sub source it says oh oh it's Bartok one
sub source any you know we knew that
steel didn't stick its stand behind it
but the other guys like saying you mean
you actually really believe that hooker
story and the Ritz in Moscow yeah and
here's the amazing thing sean is he go
through this report and you realize that
the FBI had about a million red flags
presented the second this report came in
and yet they didn't even bother to go
find this source and talk to him until
January of 2017 they could have saved
the country so much grief that they had
done basic due diligence on this guy and
his reporting and and spared us all all
right guys thank you both great work
both you the last couple of years hard
work investigative reporting